Juntos por la exploración espacial
Estados Unidos y Japón firmaron un
acuerdo con el cual buscan fomentar las
actividades espaciales conjuntas en la
luna y otros cuerpos celestes el acuerdo
llevará nuestra cooperación a nuevas
alturas reforzará nuestra asociación en
áreas como la investigación sobre
tecnología espacial y Transporte
misiones robóticas en la superficie
lunar misiones relacionadas con el clima
y nuestra ambición compartida de ver un
astronauta japonés en la superficie
lunar
la colaboración entre Estados Unidos y
Japón se remonta a varios años atrás
incluye misiones del transbordador
espacial y viajes a la estación espacial
internacional ahora se espera que
astronautas japoneses participen en la
misión Artemisa a la luna y Marte
desarrollada por la NASA espero
sinceramente que la cooperación espacial
entre Japón y Estados Unidos se
profundice aún más sobre la base de ese
acuerdo y beneficiará el futuro de toda
la humanidad
el acuerdo espacial también aclara que
en caso de que los bienes o las personas
de cualquiera de las dos naciones sean
atacados por alguna entidad extranjera
en el espacio la otra acudiría en su
defensa
los principios de la diplomacia la
democracia y el descubrimiento son los
Pilares fundamentales de la alianza
entre Estados Unidos y Japón nuestras
naciones son naciones que viajan por el
espacio naciones preparadas para
descubrir los secretos del universo
el acuerdo fue firmado en el marco de la
visita del Primer Ministro japonés
a Washington en el cual el presidente
Joe biden respaldó la nueva estrategia
de seguridad nacional adoptada
recientemente por Japón la más grande de
este país desde la Segunda Guerra
Mundial